dying light resident evil HD remaster
call of duty EXO zombies h1z1 seems like
we're five weeks into 2015 and already
the zombies have invaded kevin van noord
rajbhandari chris waters not a zombie
among us no no not yet i and y'all got
our Zombrex isn't that right or
equivalent as every day it seems to have
with when magical zombie deterrent yeah
juice good for another six hours ahh
zombies video games I think this
conversations been going on for years I
remember having this one back when dead
rising and all that sort of stuff
started kicking up again and but yeah
I'm now more than ever I feel like we
were getting inundated with zombie games
Kevin what is it about zombies that like
we keep having them in games is it just
like a super easy way of having things
to shoot that aren't thousands of
civilians I think there are tons of
reasons and the pet depends on who's
developing it what you want to do but
one of the things is that zombies can be
pretty much anything you need them to be
and so whatever you're doing you could
like like we talked about dying light
but you've got slow zombies and fast
zombies and some of them don't climb and
some of the new climb some of our huge
and have big hammers and like it's just
there's you know there's no set path
thing there's no zombie behavior we
don't witness zombies in in life I don't
think right so that I guess that's the
fella I think they can be what you
wanted to be yeah I think they feel
whatever sort of mechanism yes I is
there bipedal inhuman looking I mean
that thing with zombies is there a
stand-in for people like all right like
if we just had these games of just
massacring tongue I mean what you're
gonna make an open world and everyone's
gone crazy what's the reason uh they're
zombies but you're not like the other
the alternative is postal and you are
just so yeah not everyone's not gone
crazy I'm gone crazy I'm gonna do the
crazy thing and just murder all these
people it's so fun it's like these
fantasies of violence and power that you
live out by destroying human looking
things but your guilt free cuz they're
zombie it's kind of the only way of
having a
a game set in a place that isn't a war
zone like instead of it being like the
enemy combatant and even that like in
like in 2015's geopolitical landscape is
becoming so much more difficult than
ever before to like validate what the
war zone what does it were like who is
the body like you know obviously there
are people who we consider to be evil
and bad and on the wrong side of
whatever event is happening or war but
like that that's model muddied so much
by there to sort of I don't know but the
fact that we have much more access to
the truths of warfare as it were and
especially after living the past ten
years doing it but zombies are kind of
like a like a really easy getting yeah
it's like don't worry about it there's
even more to that too though because I
think they're conducive to certain types
of game ideas so like if you look at
something like dead island Dead Rising
type thing you know you've got like
weapon crafting systems or you've got
this whole idea where you can stick
different parts together but what are
you going to use that kind of crap on
like if I have a hobby horse and I want
to stick a shotgun on to it like what
what is my enemy in a game like that
yeah like and there's also the issue
alaban like oh yeah again you don't I
mean like that there's also the issue i
think and nah I don't think zombies are
even necessarily have to be I mean there
are enemies but there's also the idea
that you're and a lot of times you're
not even supposed to engage with them
like in dying light again and dead
rising and and in Dead Island if the
most part you you just get around them
right like it's not like a resident evil
zombie you know it's a different kind of
thing yeah the Horde is your obstacle
but your main goal is to avoid being you
know is to avoid engaging you know
unless you're just unless you're yeah
and left for dead you don't play to kill
all zombies yeah do you're gonna fail so
I think it's interesting because you
know we talked about ways that zombies
sort of allow these these new
environments to be explored in these new
game mechanics but then you have
something like call of duty zombies and
you have that in advanced warfare where
you're already in a battleground like
that's it's already set up to have you
know just tons of people you can shoot
and that's in the game why do you put
zombies there Rob you've been playing a
bunch of zombies recently what does
he's bring to this mode that like I
don't know oh just a horde mode would
write was interesting too because I have
two different kind of like viewpoints
one being like I would like my zombies
to have a reason for being a zombie
right this chorus it's just a virus but
do you you don't need any explanation
because you're just there to just hose
them down endlessly there's no there's
not there's only a little bit of like
narration you can throw in something
like this where's this wave after wave
after wave what about something like
dying light so dying light is i think i
wish i would have liked what seen a
little better like you know maybe diving
into like you know why is there a bomber
zombie who blows and they they they
barely tap on that if i were to like my
favorite friends instance is like a game
that is like really unique you know like
last of us mmm like yes they I mean you
could say they're yeah they're not
zombies but they at least went out of
their way in like like develop something
really unique and they took you know
like an actual fungus that does that
insects um you're kind of developed it
into something more something different
so that is not the weird thing it's like
you mentioned the last of us and then
you know on the opposite end of the
spectrum you've got this ridiculous EXO
zombies thing we've had resident evil
which is like a horror game which you
couldn't really say about maybe the last
of us slightly and then you've got dying
light which is just like an open world
exploration game which again just so
happens to have zombies like they'd seem
to fit into every single like genre like
where's our zombie soccer game do you
know what's that you know what's
interesting like when I when I start
thinking about you going through those
games too I think about how many of them
I mean they're all zombie games but how
many of them are actually about zombies
like I play the walking dead sure there
are zombies everywhere but that's not
they're not it's walking dad's not
really about zambia it's about fight for
survival it's it's it's about the human
connection and the kinds of you know
connections that you you gain in a world
like that how do you survive and how do
you thrive or i look even resident evil
i mean the zombies are there but i don't
know like the threat always seems to be
something different than than just a
zombie alone and eventually it ends up
being hunters as well anyway yeah i mean
i mean it's it's more about to me like
resonate like Ellis resonable
for and I don't even think it's really
about the zombies so much as I think
it's just about staying safe and secure
and it's not really about killing
zombies and eventually they've stepped
away from that like five and six or
might as well well they're there just
like pure zombie games yeah that point
but no but they might as well be zombies
they're like different types of zob they
step so far away from what Riley's are
they might as well have been zombies by
that stage and its really wait like I
feel like the only game that falls into
this is actually beds armies or
something like maybe dead rising which
does that thing where zombies are the
kind of like a metaphor for you know in
that game going back to like old zombie
movies of all like you know capitalism
and like fervor and science but even
then it's not about zombies you know
what I mean like it's not about the
zombies you see on the screen it's about
our zombification and even beyond that
like the original dead rising it's all
about it's all about using time and you
know in that case the zombie horde is an
obstacle to you completing things you
need to get done quickly they're not
there necessarily for you to kill I mean
they're there to kill but I mean I don't
I think of something is like house of
the dead or something like that maybe is
more pure just Zambia game that's
actually about zombies typing of the
Dead the best zombie game I'm afraid
yeah I'm not sure that a game like is a
game really ever about zombies like is a
platformer really ever about spike pits
like zombies are you touched on it
before Kevin there in terms of a game
mechanic in terms of building a world
they're so versatile as just a way to
make a place threatening but I way to
control that level of threat and have
just such a wide degree of freedom i
mean the zombies in walking dead are
like very low-key but then you have the
zombies in left 4 dead that I'll barf on
you and explode like have giant tongues
and you know the zombies in dying light
get pretty wild you know don't leave the
stuff that they do so like what's the
difference i guess like what's the
difference between zombies as just sort
of threat a threat party environment and
like when you're fighting aliens like
fighting the Covenant in Halo or you
know fighting the Chimera in resistance
like what's the difference between
zombies
enemy and just entirely specially
designed alien or other kind of enemy
yeah because I'm like one of the things
I'm a Robbie did you're like it's a 12
different types of zombies that are
enjoying lights all right like I could
even see in the comments for this
episode of the lobby when it went up
it's just people saying zombie suck
zombies are played out there and I
remember times feeling that this month
like you've played free zombie games you
played h1z1 which is basically a you
know copy of a game that's been out for
a couple years anyway even a backplate
AZ which is where to yeah yeah the call
of duty EXO zombies which is another
game that we we've had zombies in call
of duty before sure and and then of
course dying light as well so like
you've been pretty much in the trenches
on zombies are you sick of them like
today I did two weeks of it yeah I am I
am sick of them um I would like to say
that I will never play zombie game ever
but that's not the case you know I'm
definitely just tired of it but he'll
know is our zombies going anywhere I
mean it's just a matter of like bringing
them into a new light for me at least
now I would like to see them someone
like I said with like last of us like
that kind of blew me away it was like oh
that's really cool they they kind of
went out of the way to like explain a
situation as opposed to just going for
the cliche like zombies here you go yeah
yeah between dash between the last of us
and the walking dead as you were saying
Evan like two of the most like
critically lauded and like commercially
successful games over the past couple
years and do you see like zombies going
away anytime soon no I was just as well
as a mechanism there they're useful and
I think it's all I think the Le the
alien thing actually brings up a good
point too because whether you're making
I mean whether you're making aliens or
zombies you can create forms of behavior
that you you don't have to do in people
and you can make them very simple forms
of behavior this is the aggressive one
this is I mean not not I mean sometimes
you get the you know something like I
don't know the the Covenant and Halo or
something like that which would be
really smart and stuff like that but for
the most part you program people you
want them to be human like and so we
notice when they're behaving in ways
that don't make sense you make zombies
you can do whatever you want with them
and just like this is what that one does
so like some of the time why they just
like get outs like what are we going to
get to this
stage where we're playing a game that
isn't either a zombie or on the complete
opposites scale as you're saying crows
like postal which is just so ridiculous
like will we ever have a game where like
like certain moments in the last was
actually where you are like pointing a
gun at a human being and you are like
making a moral decision and it's not
just oh it's fine they're Undead or
they're the bad guy what we already had
didn't isn't no Russian kind of like the
real people equivalent of that and
modern warfare 2 if you had any player
agency in that situation maybe can you I
mean that's the thing like you can't do
that with people unless you want to feel
like a horrid human being I mean I guess
there are people that are making games
like that too like hey I don't know
hatred sounds like that kind of game
right looks like a real trash as well
but someone who enjoyed postal 2 I mean
[ __ ] estimate piece of [ __ ] zombies
and aliens are both easy because you can
let the player have a power fantasy and
just mow down as many as they want
without any kind of moral or social
repercussion for enjoying that well
Kevin what was that game that came out
maybe two years ago and it was a
downloadable xbox live arcade title
where you're like in the ruins of old
chicago and it's very washed out oh
you're escorting a game yeah alive I'm a
lot yeah on that game you do you know
you resources are very scant but you
have a gun and you come across like
groups of bandits and there's a mechanic
in there like you pull out the gun to
threaten them and then their behavior
changes and then but you know like in
some situations they're going to attack
you or maybe they're going to go on
their way and so it that game kind of
took took it like made violent
encounters like the peak not sort of the
norm Ryan operate on it would be like
whoa like even pulling out a gun is
super dramatic and so I think we do have
games that sort of get it what you're
what you're thinking you know what that
will make the trigger pull that
meaningful but that's really hard to do
as a trigger pull is like when you're
pointing it at someone like this does
like the unthinkable to most of us and
to confront the real life you slay me
normal I mean that has to be so so
intense and so constructed like as a
game mechanic I mean technology changed
it to I think like res it i'll look at
something like Resident Evil One and
it's like you weren't it's not like
there was eight
hoard that you were facing your fear
facing one or two or three at a time the
most you get is like Oh a couple dogs
come through the thing you know but then
as technology has been good it's like we
want to have seven trillion uh moving
things like icing on it one time yeah
totally wow the [ __ ] and and that
changed the way we think of zombies and
as well the way just pop culture in
general like now when I think zombies I
think of something like The Walking Dead
and now it's it's no longer about it we
don't trees amies quite the same way now
it's more about the human story that
develops among survivors right that's
very much to me the the current way we
look at zombie stuff that's h1z1 that's
what it is that's yeah busy this your
experiences with other players no one
even cares that zombies nothing it's who
you're talking to who can you trust
probably and that's gonna be mostly no
one right it is that's you're exactly
right survival instincts and stuff it's
interesting the for us player 2 zombies
are we actually got quite a lot to
discuss there in terms of like how they
affect different games in the domeki
than the way that which like the
different genres they cross into as well
so it doesn't look like we're missing
out on zombie games anytime soon and let
us know what you think about zombie
games are they played at or do you have
any favorite said you didn't we didn't
mention as a lot of snow in the comments
below
you